and how do you know when your film is
festival ready well I mean I don't know
if it's a I don't know if it's festive
already is really the right where I
think it said I'm gonna be honest it's
the quality of the film right I mean if
the film's is of the best calibrate that
film can be like if the film is like if
the filmmakers intent was to make a say
a short story about a child's first love
you know in school or you know I'm
starring random you know if that story
is told the best way possible and it is
an is complete and it's a strong film
then Dennis vessel ready now I may not
fit every festival you know there is
festivals every check films like get
into really good festivals and then
sometimes you know we've had this
instance where one time we rejected the
film and they wrote back over I got into
this vessel at festival the two
interrelated did not relate it I mean
they're not related it's two separate
things what we look at is what we're
looking to program is separate of course
than any other festival right i mean we
had on what we handle we have a certain
policy we have a certain way of judging
films and other festivals have theirs
but if a film is very good and completed
and done to the best it can possibly be
then that's vessel right i mean know
whether it's every festival or not
that's a whole different i guess
questionnaire discussion but that's my
way looking at ms festival right i mean
we look at certain films and then we
make decisions based on what we feel is
the best film or films for the festival
for the program and that's how we make
our decision i mean to make it more like
to make it more simple in simple terms
so you know it's kind of that it's
basically if we feel the film is of the
best caliber it can be for that story in
for that film then i guess that's what
was Fess already I mean you know I know
it doesn't really answer in a certain
way but it's it's that's how I look at
it like festival ready or not as more
just is the film is a film was not good
then we feel is not up to up to par then
essentially it's not festival right
Riley's for us now maybe for other
festivals they might look at it
differently but that's that's kind of as
how we look at that
you